[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett joining us today at the round
table of them lighting is Joseph Garrett
the creator and voice of one of the most
popular minecraft avatars on the
interwebs
stampy cat his minecraft focus YouTube
channel called stampylonghead boasts
over 5.8 million subscribers and 3.5
billion views his popularity and I say
that again 3.5 billion yeah you can see
his money I love that being stutter now
his popularity amongst children is
unprecedented so much so the
Entertainment Weekly called him the mr.
Rogers of Minecraft he was not wearing a
cardigan no arts talking to a trolley
when he came in here though but he a
legitimate publication has called him
the Mister Rogers of Minecraft and that
does it for me if you're in grade school
or know someone in grade school chances
are you've heard of stampy cat his voice
is an almost constant presence in my
home I'm not complaining you know I sat
down with Lily and said alright I got to
figure out this minecraft stamping hat
thing and I was kind of sucked in and I
think you're from the conversation
you'll kind of hear that there's a level
of fascination that I have for what he's
done because it's so much different than
what I thought it was I mean he's got
the voice very distinctive here's a
montage it's just everywhere
maybe she'd give me a baby shake Oh
[Music]
check that out how about that we can hit
go and light up the cruise ship in the
night you know but it's not just the
voice it's not just any one thing it's a
it I think we hit on a bunch of things
that are the key to the culmination of
his success coming together a
family-friendly character based on
Minecraft 20-minute daily videos full of
imagination and ingenuity it's not your
typical let's play these are planned and
executed much like a television show
really storytelling humor friendly
characters villains plot lines mixed
into ingenuitive minecraft building
projects yeah we had a great time
sitting down with Joseph and talking
about this creative process
incredibly detailed and why he insist on
doing most of it himself also talked
about his new show that is filmed
entirely within the world of Minecraft
and how he gets cameras I'm using air
quotes cameras into Minecraft that was
fascinating to me is remarkably simple
but I never thought about it before
and how spending so much time playing
Minecraft actually led to him getting a
girlfriend who first time ever makes an
appearance we have a girlfriend
appearance on the pack yes so be sure to
stick around for that but first we want
to take a moment to tell you guys about
our song biscuits volume 1 album
available on iTunes if you haven't
checked it out already we got a whole
season of the songs we wrote oftentimes
collaborating with guests on ear
biscuits like within an hour so we wrote
those song you remember you guys tweeted
us and told us what the right songs
about now
it's all available on write all these
were on good mythical morning you can go
watch those there were Saturday videos
for 15 weeks in a row but I think you'll
enjoy it
yeah they were designed not just to be
watched but to go right into your ear
holes and so we have massively crafted
those to go right into your ear holes by
putting them on iTunes that's pretty
much how it works I think they're also
available on Amazon anyway be helpful if
you go over there and leave it
in a review and of course buying it's
always helpful to appreciate that and
now on to the biscuit with stampy cat
[Music]
they said you had more videos than
Bieber yes so everyone wanted to talk
about but it's just the first article
when whenever they state something
everyone just picks up on it and so the
first big article about me said more
views than Justin Bieber like on YouTube
which is he's not youtuber so it was a
matter anyway for like yeah right he
sold more songs than make it I felt like
now every time it's introduced is like
more views than Justin Bieber like that
phrase has stuck with me for like two
and a half years or something you know
because one person mentioned it you know
kind of copy and paste it yeah yeah that
sounds good that sounds real good why
right when you can copy and paste yeah
so we basically that was my philosophy
well in English class growing up this is
probably a good time to tell you that we
just took that BBC article and we we're
gonna go put that away
so we met this is our second meeting in
person first one was in France yeah
backstage at the whatever it was I don't
you know it's still fuzzy on what it was
we just knew it was a trip to France and
so we went you had a similar situation
to me so some wants you to speak in
front in Cannes okay yeah yeah I'll
speak will go I gotta speak I having
never been to Europe I had you have but
I had never been to Europe I've never
been to France and meeting you was a
highlight because then I was able to
have bragging rights with my kids and a
little iPhone video from you to them
that went a long long way yeah
we remain we're still dad's to this day
because of that iPhone video I mean it
would have been over a few weeks ago
they would they would have disowned us
it probably would've been a few weeks
back right you know well I kept your
family life intact I don't know if you
remember I told you when I made the
video but going over there I was like
you know stampy's gonna be at this thing
I'm telling Lincoln and Lily cuz they
watch it religiously lando now does to
who's fine
so he's finally getting into he's
finally getting it um I said you know
there's a chance we can meet stamping
he's gonna be there and they were like
what do you want me to tell them and
Lincoln said well just just tell stampy
you you're my biggest fan but I'll tell
him I mean it's amazing when when you
meet people that you know like other
youtubers that you know that you respect
and been watching for a while and you
got to them you're like how am I gonna
save some I'm a bit nervous then they
come up to you in they're like hey it's
it's time for your hair like it's so
great to see you it's like you know like
you know the fact they've heard of you
and you know it's it's not because they
got kids that watch you you know with me
but that's always an exciting thing well
you know it's funny cuz I mean it's
probably a little bit of a fickle thing
but I've told my wife this before that
it it is helpful sometimes when your
reputation precedes you when you go into
a group because a lot of times when you
do what we do for a living like I was in
I was at a birthday party a week ago
with a bunch of people who are more
friends than my wife than than me and no
one really yeah I knew what we what I
did and so then you kind of like I'll
kind of start explaining what it's a
moment when you you have to decide if
you're going to really hey am I gonna do
like I'm a video producer let's just
leave it at that because you are in LA
and you can understand what that is
because if I say I make youtube videos
then it just there's all these questions
that come up and then it that's it's
just like it's I don't want to be in
that conversation but when somebody has
that like oh no no I get it I get it and
I like it I mean it's a little bit
selfish obviously but do you deal with
that but yeah I mean imagine there's an
extra level of explaining that the
videos you do are playing video games
you know you could send in one of your
videos or a podcast and they they get
you know that yeah but close enough to
to something they can understand if I
have to explain that or I make videos on
YouTube or what do you do is like have
you heard of Minecraft
you don't like yeah yeah yeah if they
say yes or no then you know that you
know whether it's gonna be a 10 minute
or an hour conversation of explaining
exactly what you do yeah and then and
then you if you go there if you say I'm
going to
do the long explanation so you will know
exactly what it is I do you get to the
end of this 15 minute explanation in
there kinda like it doesn't matter I
mean have you ever just dropped a bomb
on somebody and by the way I have 3
billion views you know it's like I'm I
think I have enough read on you to know
that you would probably never say that
but maybe you would know I mean like
it's what you gotta pull out the big gun
and just buy out the first people
generally we most people I meet kind of
just know if you know if I might like a
family thing of people know or meeting
friends you know people Germany there
are even other youtubers and so no or
kind of have heard that I do something
you know especially with kids because
you know they it'll be someone whose
child watches me or someone's auntie's
kids watching me say hey the kind of the
connection gets through so they don't
really understand what I do but they
know that you know little Billy loves me
for some reason that kind of makes it
easy I mean what I've been told and I've
given advice for when when going through
customs when I went out to say is it
work or pleasure if I have to say work
is just to say I'm in advertising and
probably that's the easiest way because
then they're like okay whatever they're
not interested I don't I just let you go
that's good and the follow-up answer is
just what pre-roll ads yeah you know and
I mean other integrations if you really
want to talk about it you know but it's
an internet thing right it's an internet
thing you three billion music understand
you missed our scooter adventure in
France you know the day after we met you
yeah I saw huh I saw you speaking about
it I heard about it oh man there was one
of the highlights of our lives and and
we're not joking
like I mean we each had our own scooter
but we've had our wife on the back of
the senator knows what a great
experience going up to what's it what's
a car Monaco Monaco yeah next time man
you get your scooter you come with us I
also remember you being fascinated by
the toilets as well was that another yes
I'm a fan of bidets and fancy toilets oh
yeah yeah fancy toilets in London and
you know if if you're in a nice
restaurant is good if you're in a train
station
long night but the the bidet is is is
not so much an English thing alright I
mean you have them but it's not like in
every bathroom no I mean I mean Europe
and you know that's gonna say Europe and
England very similar Europe's in England
yes anglers in Europe the other way
around you know but you know it's this
is very similar like it's you do have a
bidet at your house in your apartment
yeah you get sent one by the by by the
Queen at a certain age when you turn 13
there a London thing - oh okay alright
maybe I'll visit now now that I know
that I think I there's a lot that I want
to talk about I think kind of in one of
the first places I wanted to go was I
mean just in the videos that I've
watched with Lily I mean she's the most
religious viewer in our house it I
quickly find out it's not a typical just
watch me play minecraft I mean there's a
there's a lot that goes into the various
different types of videos that you play
but I I just want you to walk us through
a typical episode within your lovely
world what are those called
just the lovely world yeah yeah there's
no one your name of the series that the
video is in my lovely world side and so
this this is my that's my main series
and that's right I put most time into
and they're my most planned videos so
right oh yeah as you know you deducted
I'm not just pressing record like I know
kind of the the beginning middle and end
of what the episodes gonna be so so walk
us through it for someone who hasn't
watched yet okay so a typical episode is
I'd be building either a new shop or a
mini game or something but before I even
think about building it of come up with
you like seven doing a mini game I can't
with the idea of the game I've come up
with a theme then I then entirely build
it in a in a separate world to practice
it have people come in and test playing
it with me and then I'll kind of go into
the world and then work out well if I
built this much in one episode then we
could kind of test playing it'll be a
fun ending and then in the next episode
we can do this part and then you know I
work out three episodes which we spent
building and then playing
game right so the pre-production I mean
I could just tell watching one 20-minute
video it there's a lot that goes into
this but from a from an audience's
perspective walk us through from that
perspective I mean right from the go
there's a few things that I can count on
as a viewer right yeah more than a few
things yeah the word the first words out
of your mouth hello this is stumpy and
welcome to a minecraft let's play video
that's how it always starts and that's
you know it must not planned intro but
people love that familiarity I always
start in the same place and the the
beginning routine is we're in you're
saying yeah so you you're in your house
you're kind of talking to the audience
but the character is looking at the
camera so to speak yeah so you've got
that that viewpoint I always talk
directly to the view I never say like
well would all of you like this I always
say you know would you like this like
I'm always speaking to a new yeah yes in
the camera but the camera is looking at
stampy the character yeah well the
majority of time it's just the
first-person perspective so they're just
seeing what stampy would be seeing if
you know if he was in in that world so
stampy leaves his house there's usually
like there's a pet bit and then there's
a garden bit I mean walk me through all
of that
okay so always start off with in my room
that has kind of changed a bit over the
years I always have a cake for breakfast
is a is a must because always I'm not
happy for the rest of the the video and
then I go to the love garden which is
basically a place where anyone who sent
me fan out or a great video or just on
anything cool then I put their name down
in a sign and say thank you so say
someone has you know decorated an
amazing wall in like stampy cat collars
or something then real life yeah yeah
then I'll put a picture of that up and
say thanks for doing that you know
that's really awesome welcome to my love
guard and then that's a sign in my world
which will stay there forever so every
video when I go to the live guard and
then see their their sign which is a
cool thing yeah in the garden is pretty
huge if you're do because you make a
video every single day yeah not not in
the library I do two videos a week in
that series and originally there was a
sign each there's now they now have to
share sign
kind of like burying people in a
cemetery at a certain point you got to
start stacking pieces yeah well it's
kind of like the round table of dim
lighting here you know villagers on top
of each other yeah I don't to be the
first person to have to write the
underneath of the table there is one
under there but just to clarify the fans
in your love garden they had they're not
deceased mmm I just want for anyone
listening being diseased is not required
at some point you bring a pet along so
there's like you know you've got you've
got pets you've got dogs in the
Minecraft world that have names that
you're you're choosing one to be your
companion yeah like people like animals
a lot and I find having animals is good
I mean having animals in Minecraft is
great because like the thing that I do
is is so planned like most of it but the
commentary is unscripted and things can
happen in the video which I didn't plan
and you just go with it like the dog can
suddenly jump off something orb set off
some TNT or something and having animals
with kind of crazy AI running around is
an amazing thing to add humor to a video
yeah and you just to pretend like you
know I speak to them as if they
understand ER so Phil you're looking
happy today oh you go enough to explore
this you know so like I'm always making
up this most the story as I go along
then it's the same with other characters
in the videos I have other people that
join me who have real people controlling
characters but they don't speak they can
hear me but they don't speak so I could
look at a character could leave their
who's a big bear I go oh no you look
upset today you know he's just standing
there and then so he would then react to
me and then I'll make up oh did you lose
your thing you know so I can make up a
kind of a story on the fly and you don't
and this is never I mean as far as I've
seen it's never montage tit this is a
it's this is a single twenty-something
minute long the episode yeah so 20
minutes straight commentary just me
speaking you know sometimes it'll go
wrong and I'd be like there's a lot of
time I'll get close to the end I'm like
nothing happened like this is boring
like and I just go and start again like
that happens a lot or like a lot um so
yeah don't you're that in 18 minutes in
and you're like this is got to the I've
been editing a video and been watching
it back and being like no this isn't
like I'm not I'd like this isn't
entertain there's no
nothing everything just went as it was
supposed to that's boring like it went
too well it was it was just fine so
instead of having an edit trick like I'm
a splice in there I'm gonna create an
alternate ending you start over it's
just because it's lies yes it's real
it's you know if I'm building something
I'm actually you know I'm doing it all
there but but you only thing you built
you'd have to tear down and then rebuild
you can kind of just quit without saving
and then go back which is what which I
what I do a lot good they're typical
episodes I then have special episode
which take the planning goes even
further to you know I do an episode
where I go to space and I build a rocket
I want to talk about that yeah but
before we do just continue walking me
through though and I like the details of
it because you'll pick your dog
sometimes you'll take it you know you'll
have your the other person who's playing
with you and then you'll go and you'll
build a a game it but then you want
usually you won't finish it but then
you'll go and you're okay that'll be the
first half you're actually doing like
construction and creation of a I like it
it kind of like on Survivor where like
everyone's doing a physical challenge
it's kind of like a really fun minecraft
version of a of a game a physical
challenge game like that within the game
you're building that but then at some
point you go to another game that you
finish and you play that and it's like a
competition with stakes yes I so usually
like I don't want I never I never want
videos to be just building for 20
minutes so normally you know what the
ending are going like oh we're play just
a game I've already built just as a fun
ending and so but when I'm when I'm
actually building I'm really being very
conscious to kind of teach what I'm
building because a lot of the time
people copy what I've built and build it
in their own world so I'm being very
particular about you know placed ten
blocks along this way or then if I'm
doing there's something called a
redstone in the game which is kind of
like wire rings you can do like
mechanical things have Pistons and
buttons and things and if I'm doing
anything like that I'm very particular
in terms of like this is how you know
then it becomes slightly more you know
it's always entertainment first but then
it's a bit more of a guide or you know
giving people ideas at least so what
percentage of your time now is devoted
to
planning versus the execution in in the
world it's pretty much like the
recording is 20 minutes it's the
recording is the length of the video the
planning can take for a lovely world
episode you know I don't need only be at
least of a full day planning the the
episode and then I normally record it
the next day but even coming up with
those games that they're the intricate
nature of these things there's a
mechanical nature and it's just
whimsical but it's I mean it's something
all these things you're talking about
are things that like a top-notch
television producer would hire a team of
20 people half of the people in the room
would just be writers to devise this
type of stuff but that that's where the
that's where I think the value is like
people can strike my commentary I think
I'm fine like I'm getting better like I
think a lot of people attribute most
success of mine to the commentary and I
don't think that I think my country's
fight like it it does what it needs to
do but it's the the planning and you
know being able to come up and a new
idea each week and and it's not even an
idea of building something that looks
cool or plays well it's got to play well
in my format or video like I can come up
with with a game where the other person
needs to speak so it needs to be easy to
understand and even building it I don't
want to build something too big so I'll
be boring if I'm building like a
skyscraper like I'm spacing rows of
blocks like the building process has to
be fun as well yeah I would agree I mean
the commentary the person every it's a
total package
but the ingenuity associated with and
you only have to watch as a producer you
only have to watch one to really
appreciate kind of the genius of the the
amount of ingenuity that goes into it
and you're with each one you're building
another game it's it's amazing really
and kind of what I hear you saying that
answer though is that you haven't
necessarily found someone yet that you
can get to do those things for you
because you know you're still doing all
of it I I haven't even looked for
someone like that's that mean that's
what I enjoy most is when I'm in
Minecraft and I'm just planning or like
just scribbling on a whiteboard and
working out
that's like that that's the fun part I
mean I love recording as well but that's
what I really enjoy and there's some of
that I've got an editor so a lot of you
know the that side of thing is you know
things that I don't need to be as
involved in because you know there's
generally little editing because you
know as you said it's 20 minutes
straight no cuts so there's not a huge
amount that needs to be done but like I
just do all the hard parts you've got an
editor is nothing he's did you invent
the format I mean we would you emulate
it emulating or inspired by someone else
who was taking the world of Minecraft
and then bending it to to be
pre-produced as a show in this way or
did you just invent it over time like
yeah it was I mean if you look at an
early episode compared to now like that
wasn't the initial format I mean the
lovely world I don't I'm almost done
pretty just I hit 300 episodes now so
and if you look at Episode one it's in
no way similar to any later episodes I
kind of just kept adding on aspects and
but no one else was doing it so you're
you are saying that you invented it over
time there's this format that you've
arrived at yeah yeah I guess I was kind
of naturally doing there weren't many
people doing family-friendly content on
Minecraft when I began well when I
started was when minecraft first came
out for consoles and that is when a lot
of children and on phones as well in
tablets that's where a lot of children
started playing because before that
minecraft was like a hardcore gamers
game as a weird game you can only get
online and you know a lot of the
elements of it you know you kind of had
to know some basic coding to do some
things and it was it was not a
kid-friendly game and it was only when
it came to consoles did kids start
playing and I started playing and so I
think my timing was just so lucky the
fact that I started doing videos as kids
started playing and I think that is kind
of a big reason why it was successful
but the fact that you developed again
the format of okay they're gonna be
twenty minutes you know why 20 minutes
was that how long a television show is
is that why I think it just seemed that
that's a good length to have a beginning
middle and an end
which is which is I guess why you know
22 minutes was became the the time that
TV did it as well you know like it's you
know there's enough time for you to to
starts to explain what you're doing
start the
idea then you've got a good middleware
you're creating it and then you have you
know three or four minutes at the end
for a fun ending but you know I never
there was not once when I sat down and
worked fought like okay I should start
in the room and then I should go to the
love garden and like that I never once
fought about that it was instinct it
just kind of happened and then people
picked up and it people were like like I
did one episode where I didn't start in
my room like oh why didn't you start in
your room that's like oh that's the
thing now like that that just I guess I
will doubt yeah like that's what that's
how I start like it's interesting that
you know Entertainment Weekly called you
the Mister Rogers of Minecraft and it's
that it's that repetition and it's that
pattern and it's I mean it's also the
target audience I guess but it's so
powerful you know I even fell mice like
once I watched Italy I was like I get it
I get it I can come back to this you
know he was one of his dogs then he ran
off and he doesn't know where it is but
he did that on purpose I bet I bet I'm
gonna find out to next time that that
dogs coming back this guy's a genius
I want to know what happened to the dog
with the dogs fine I just want to rest
to show that straight away the dogs fine
I mean don't lie a lot of your dogs have
died I hope don't don't be like the dog
is fine how many dogs have died and
where do you bury him well I bury them
where they died I mean that's actually
kind of and it's not a nice thing but
that is a nice way to kind of add a bit
of a message in because there's always
if a dog died you know they're always
buried and you know I can always say a
little thing about like you know them
being remembered and things so that's
kind of that's something that I've not
shied away from there are certain dogs
that I feel that if they died people
would be too upset that couldn't happen
but especially the early save that one
old so a bad dog dies is just start over
yeah yeah yeah has that happened yeah
very you know but not read but once you
once you quit out the game it's it's
back to school yeah yeah you know it's
kind of travel which dog are we talking
about here and like you know I I don't
know any I don't know any specific
example cut off my head but it's but you
know that these dogs are meaningful to
the audience
so yeah I know that I've diverted
destiny for a few new favorite
characters they're playing God in
Minecraft I love it
well I mean you talk about the audience
and kind of changing making your content
more age-appropriate yeah and it's it's
not like every youtuber doesn't knows
that kids are watching their stuff what
what made you make a decision because
you made a strategic decision early on
that okay you know you weren't gonna you
were gonna use foul language you were
gonna keep it kid-friendly you know but
but you didn't have to and and most
people don't and it's just it's a choice
it was it was a moral decision rather
than a strategic one cuz you know that
was still at a point where YouTube
wasn't even in the back of my head an
idea for a career like that was you know
that was pure hobby like I mean there
was a you know I for years I did non
child friendly content on YouTube just
as a hobby you know no one was watching
but I think air and then when minecraft
came out I noticed kids were watching
and so you know I thought like oh I
can't if kids are watching I can't be
swearing like but I I was happy to
change and I'm so glad I did now because
I think that was you know the the big
reason why more kids started watching
and you know parents you know trusted me
at that point you know they were and
yeah and I and we can say from the
perspective of parents who have kids who
are fans of yours yeah I mean we
definitely appreciate that and that's in
that's I think that's something that we
think about because we are parents so it
kind of came like we started YouTube as
parents so you know I've always just
kind of thought oh yeah most of these
single people they just they just don't
know that they're not thinking beyond
just the immediate experience that
they're having so I'm not thinking like
oh like 75% of my audience is like
really young kids so maybe I should
think about what I'm saying
so we as a parent we appreciate that
yeah I mean it was it was never seeing
like I didn't see a gap in the mark
you know I didn't say oh here's this big
untapped audience it was you know that
audience was there and I saw they were
on my channel and I was like okay I
better you know tailor my content to the
people that want to say I mean I mean I
say I didn't make child-friendly stuff
like I was never vulgar like it was just
you know it was more it just wasn't
intended
yet my commentary was like I am in this
conversation I wasn't you know I was
speaking as I'm speaking now which is
you know it's just fine but it's you
know it's not gonna grab anyone's
attention right and you're not gonna
like just drop an expletive when you
when you feel angry you're gonna you're
gonna hold back a little bit yeah and
even more so than that I'm gonna I'm not
gonna get angry I'm gonna understand the
situation and you know like you're never
gonna see stampy you know getting like
you say if he loses you know you know
having a big tournament and I lost my
loads
I'm never gonna be angry no it's like oh
well but we all had fun you know it's
it's it's a road those messages it's
this you know it's not my emotions at
that point it's you know it's stampy's
and it's not like it's different being
fake as well because you know if I'm
laughing like that's you know that's
like that's laughing like if a song if I
turn a corner and there's a zombie and
it makes me job like that's all real but
then there's other things where I can
tailor things to make it a little bit
better than real life like a little bit
happier as an entertainer and what's the
most what's the largest scale project
that you've done is it the the rocket
launch that you were mentioning earlier
um there's a probably the money my
Easter special this year was quite big
that was a like a choose your own
adventure style video so where it
started off as an Easter egg hunt where
there would be a riddle left by the
Easter Bunny and I've got to work at
where the egg is and then eventually I'm
attacked by a villain and then it
becomes like do you attack the villain
or do you try and talk to him and then
you know so that was a good 20 plus
episode you did short videos and those
were clickable annotations to different
videos yeah yeah and and I cards as well
so it worked on phones so yes yeah 2 to
0 never so that was quite a big one
they're flying to the moon one was a big
one because in in Minecraft that there
isn't a moon you can go to so I give it
all to the moon yeah give us the concept
i watch the behind the scenes video you
know I want you to explain it because it
was just kind of taking minecraft from
being a game and turn it into a
cinematic tool yeah it would became
video editing software
feck software in every it was it blew my
mind when I watched it behind the scenes
so what did you want to do what was the
first idea yes and this is actually it's
actually a really controversial video if
you can believe it for really weird
reason so what I love to do is to take
the game and do things that you couldn't
normally do in the game but make it like
like it's never like oh I've added in a
flying dragon which obviously doesn't
fit in it always is supposed to always
look like it is just the game and I just
kind of never acknowledge it and it's
just you know that's what it is where
it's flying to the moon or traveling
back in time or going around in a
submarine like I like to do these bigger
videos and they're you know they're
always more popular so I did a video
where I made it look like I was flying
to the moon and I met aliens and the
moon was powered by Luna cheese which I
gave it up from the moon is like you
know this big video and that's when I
knew you were fake when it was power
that was it's powered by naughty
children
turning cogs right no yes I said the
process of making that that video was
you know I tried to build the moon which
was you know a month long project I had
help building of you know we're placing
block by block building the surface of
the moon and there's a sphere of lunar
scape well I was able to I pretended we
couldn't see beyond the horizon so I
didn't have to build I was able to build
a flat plane and assume that the rest
wouldn't be wouldn't be seen so I mean
that was a big thing you know in itself
and then I had to build a recreation of
a huge rocket ship that I built in my
world and then you know I had to then
get the transition perfect from me
flying up into the the sky and then you
know loading up and brand new world and
then editing it as if I land and trying
to make it look seamless right so you
get it you you built you build the
rocket like the audiences along for the
ride watching you and the struggling
rocket on your plan on your in your
world the lovely world yeah yeah you get
in the rocket and it's like alright
launch sequence initiate and then you
see the rocket take off this cannot
happen in Minecraft roots going up you
can see the you see the skyline
disappear and the Rockets it's it's
it's in orbit well it's out of orbit and
then you see it just come down on them
on the moon
kind of like the space X rocket like it
came down but first right yeah full of
video logistical reasons
yeah there's the thing with that is it's
those mean the rocket one was I mean
some people might have guessed that
something would have happened but it's
always just happens within what would
seem like a normal episode so they would
never know when that things like that
are gonna happen like I love to surprise
the audience and so I'll be having a
totally normal episode I'm building a
bakery and then suddenly you know a UFO
comes down and suddenly something big
happens and then there's this quick
adventure and they have no idea you know
when it's coming you know sometimes I do
like a build-up to it that I leave clues
in a few episodes leading up to it and
how are you I say physically editing
these things you're like exporting
capture footage from Minecraft into like
Final Cut yeah yeah I was I was at that
point so I did his that wives was
controversial because it was you were to
using editing tricks it don't yeah the
word the worry yet the controversy was
the fact that I got accused of like
faking a video and like you know and how
did you find out about that like what
was it just a bunch of comment well it
was actually the I uploaded a I knew
that after cuz that the moon one was the
first big video like that you know so
that when you broke the rules yeah yeah
and so I knew I was going to get comment
saying how did you do that
but I thought they were all gonna be how
did you edit that I didn't realize they
were gonna be how did you fly the moon
in Minecraft yeah they're like all
racking their brains how do we do this
in the game so I uploaded I I made at
the same time I made a behind the scenes
where every I recorded every process and
I made a video pouch stamp you flew to
the moon because I knew people were
gonna you know wanted to know how I did
it thinking the editing tricks assuming
they would know but then would they
would find this video and be like oh so
you faked it you didn't actually fly to
the you made out as if you flew to them
you were tricking us and I was like nice
too entertaining you hopefully you know
like I was you know like I didn't you
know I was a bit short-sighted on my
side like I was
didn't realize that people would assume
that I was actually doing this thing you
know I thought I was making you know a
cool entertaining video but I got yeah I
mean it's just a minority you know but
it was how did learning that that people
had an expectation or at least some
people had an expectation for this to be
an authentic minecraft experience how
did that impact you moving forward and I
I often now in videos like that at the
very end say something along the lines
of like you know like say like I hope
you enjoyed this you know this this
special video and kind of try and word
it to make it obvious that you know like
it you know like this wasn't fake I hope
you just enjoyed this this special thing
I made for you you like I try and leave
something like that but it hasn't really
changed too much like I keep trying to
step up to beat the the previous thing
and you know and there are a lot of
people that aren't thinking about the
behind the scenes and whether they think
it's in Minecraft or not I just really
enjoying these videos you know they
always end up more popular and you know
they're they're kind of the the people
are mainly making the the videos for
like it hasn't hasn't put me off make
you know kind of doing that kind of
thing right because that's how you're
that's one of the ways that you're kind
of pushing the pushing the boundaries of
the space yeah it's just something
something a little bit different and
I've done you know quite a few videos in
that that style now where you know it's
probably what once every 2 or 3 months
there's just this video that kind of
comes out of nowhere which always seems
like a normal video and then you know
something extraordinary happens what's
the next thing what's in the works give
us a hint and well they're after the the
Easter video the villain has escaped and
will be coming back soon I'm not I'm not
holding back from you guys I'll tell you
anything but I don't know exactly yet
you got to spend a month building
something whatever it is it'll be great
tell us about the pre Stampede Joe like
growing up um so I'd always wanted to
what my two obsessions were playing
video games and making videos and well
where did you grow up I grew up in the
the South of England about 15 minutes
away from where I live now it's a small
town called Emsworth it's like a fishing
village it's very on the coast
yeah yeah right right right next to the
the sea there's a writer
very happy childhood either did your dad
or mom a fisherman oh no says that sadly
not but my dad is actually a graphics
designer and did all of the stamp er
work for merchandise and things oh yeah
he actually did all of that so and then
my mum is you know number-one fan and
now like YouTube expert from looking at
you know from me going what watching
everyone else and she's number one on my
stamp you Facebook page moderating it to
see you wouldn't believe what this woman
was saying all this time through
Facebook page so you know it's kind of
become a bit of a family project now
which I would you what was she saying
[Laughter]
say what they think on Facebook yeah
I'll tell you that so you got any
siblings yeah I got two sisters two
older sisters one of which is a now
works with my dad doing a design work
and another one which has just started a
youtube career as well so it's like yeah
well we ended up I wanted to do a video
where I was getting my mum to play
Minecraft for the first time and she
would be playing and I would be kind of
guiding her and she's you know never
touched a controller in her life she
wouldn't do it and then I asked my
sister who was in the same situation to
do it and she did it and loved it and
then like a few weeks later started up a
YouTube channel doing minecraft video so
I was able to get my sister into as well
did you guys get along growing up yeah
yeah we always had yeah we were always a
really really close family I mean we
like having three moms when you have two
older sisters no because because mums
kind of you know like II I I kind of
felt like it was a bit different for for
I guess playing like I had very close
friends and you know like I wasn't
particularly interested in in in girls
toys so we were kind of close in a way
but you know we didn't we played
together a lot when we were when we were
very young but kind of as you get older
like I I was super obsessive into video
games and you know they weren't so from
there from a young age yeah well I never
actually had games consoles as a child
but all my friends did which like which
is fine but like in wise it was your
family just like we're not gonna you
should be playing those video games I
don't think I've already asked for one
like I don't know why but I I don't
think I I just I just never considered
the fact
I could have one two three until when I
was very young but but I actually liked
it now because it made video games like
really special to me because I you'll be
you know they'll be going to my friend's
house and I get to play it and I'd like
oh yeah I'm gonna go around go around
Liam's house I get to you know I get to
play the Savior I get to play the only
I'm head there saying yeah yeah I'm here
to hear all of them and I didn't have
any of them but you know so medium was
spoiled well yeah there were kids like
that they had all this all the systems
now but a huge part of who you are and
what you do now is your imagination
right and so we as somebody who has a
brain that can create a story and create
a world I always picture them as a kid
kinda lost and thought or you know
wandering around exploring and stuff
like that like how did that imagination
manifest itself when you were a kid so
when I was really young it was writing I
used to write my own stories and like I
used to get just a4 paper and like kind
of fold it together and staple it to
make books and like draw the the frog
out so that when I was really young like
that was my obsession and then you know
like mom read my new book and her you
know looking at my squiggle was trying
to understand it and then you know in an
innocent like so like we're talking I
could adventure novels about fantastical
bands of creatures what genre no nothing
nothing that good it was nothing that
girls often slightly based on video
games probably Liam's video games yeah
yeah you know there's a long-running
series called the cat and the dog which
me and my friend Lee here's that Liam's
real by the way that's a serious who
meet me and you know we were right kind
of back and forth together and so as the
only other person that would read each
other's books you know writing partner
yeah that's you know you were committed
I should have gotten link involved at
this stage because what I did is I began
writing one book when I was about 10
years old and it was about this group of
I remember people who were in this
really weird world that had like cows
would no short legs like perfectly
manicured grass and well you let me read
it and I guess my reaction didn't
inquiry is my band of friends who are
like going out across this land they
came to a huge chasm
and then like I write now I couldn't
figure out what they should do when they
got to the chasm so the book just ended
it was I'm standing at the edge of a
chasm that's why they call it writers
chasm mmm I'll let you read it as a poet
now in our in our relationship now link
would be like I've got a suggestion for
how to get across the chasm but he was
like okay yeah let's do some oatmeal
paws yeah now if I what I if the mean
now was then what I would have done was
I would have given you 20 notes the four
of them would have been really good and
would have helped you get over the chasm
but then the other 18 you just got
really mad frustrated why do the cows
have short legs that doesn't make any
sense like we get a lot of arguments so
you had a runner and Liam yeah but that
but that didn't continue no I mean that
this is very you know this is very young
but then as soon as technology caught up
to where like I could make videos then
that was the used to be animations was
my obsession I got I didn't have a video
camera but I would take my mum's digital
camera it's like stills camera and I'll
make stop motions and that's actually
where I got the the stamping name from
stampylonghead was a character in one of
these animations he had a long hair
yet he had a long head and big feet as
and then and also on the the computer
odd the way odd Anna makes I didn't have
flash or anything and if I did I
wouldn't how to use it I would I'd use
Photoshop and I would save pictures so
I'd have all my separate layers and I'd
move the eyes and then the mouse and
then I'd save a picture and then I just
shoved them all in in a timeline and you
know and then I'd make animations that
way and that was you know like I I'm one
of the people that I could sit there for
you know seven hours just just doing
that this is like high school or middle
school this is this is kind of fast
towards the the end of what would be the
lowest Kairos primary school in in
England like this will be towards the
end of day this is looking at about nine
ten eleven twelve
yeah you know that's when I was getting
obsessed with that and then as soon as I
got a video camera and you know I found
picked a group of friends that would be
interested enough to you know jump
around in front of it while I'm trying
to trying to make something then that
was the that's what I was doing you know
and this
is you know before YouTube and then to
the start of YouTube and then so as soon
as YouTube came along then that was like
okay I got a place to to put all of
these these early videos so you never
went back to actually writing anything
no I mean I was it was writing for for
video at that point I know I never went
back to just just literature this is
these are kids books the dog see as soon
as video-making like came around you
know from then until now then that was
that that was what I was gonna do not
from through school and then I did
college for two years doing TV and film
and then did video productions in
university like I I knew I was wanting
to make videos but like my obsession was
never with film I never you know I never
I didn't watch loads of films and watch
loser TV my obsession was always still
playing video games
I loved the process of making video but
then playing games so what is er what
specifically did you think the career
was gonna be um I wasn't sure I always
liked editing editing was a big thing I
liked that's why I try to specialize in
I actually before going full-time in
YouTube I was doing freelance vision
mixing like live vision mixing at events
like corporate events and things I was
doing that because that was one of the
few professional things I could do where
people would pay me to do it
Heath oh that was this I never need live
cameras which yeah yeah a little I like
life switching so we found your LinkedIn
profile online okay which still says
quote freelance video producer and
features that you were bar staff at the
railway in and that's the only only work
experience I that LinkedIn was made as
in University like I just said like like
do you have a LinkedIn to everyone and I
was like I don't know ones like if you
don't have a link to unlike make one now
yes I gotta have one of those yeah and
it still sits yeah yeah I can take it
down but it is you should but you are a
barkeep like yeah were you a bartender
or were you like yeah through University
and for a while afterwards I was I was a
bartender at the railway in yeah what
was that place like there's a as a local
English pub it was down the road from
from where I lived
they build pubs on top of
pubs over there right yeah you walk in a
pub to get to another pub right it's
like one of eight pubs in the town
square of this tiny town it's like every
other buildings a small pub and I was a
bartender in one of them we just
churches in the south it's like well you
walk through a church to get to a church
that's right right yeah it is something
like that but I mean that was a great
job for me
what I loved at a university because I'd
love the contrast of the conversations
you're having with people at university
and then going to the pub it was each
one was a nice break from the the other
rep and also I had you know I didn't
have great social skills or confidence
before then like and that was a great
way you know to be able to meet new
people each day and just be able to hold
you know conversations with people like
that something that was it was a
clientele in the real way in we talk in
middle-aged men watching football yeah
yeah yeah middle to later age aged men
you know who who are in there for
another day knows those are really nice
people there though um you know it was
it was a sport pub I had a pool table
and a dartboard and stuff so there's a
pretty good mix actually right you seen
any wicked dart accidents no and well
almost course I mean we would when the
when the pub was shut we would do crazy
darts and we'd play darts in you know
just difficult positions to throw darts
oh you know no one was there we were we
were fine but that was what are the the
things to look forward to at the end of
the shift crazy darts did you ever do
that very stereotypical thing that a
bartender does in movies where they had
to cut some old man off like late at
night like you can't no you can't have
another one is that like is that part of
the bartender's code yeah you got a deal
arguing with drunk people is one of the
the skills you pick up early on and how
to ignore knowledge like ignore ignore
logic and just alright it's just like
dealing with just really big kids at
that point yeah yeah I think that the
way you gotta you go to speak to them
right that's where you developed your
voice first ampie know talking to drunk
men who needed to be like told a walk
home
[Laughter]
that sounded nothing like they did that
was the very poor Rhett interpretation
of the very beginning of the other video
what's your your day-to-day like now I
mean let's get let's talk social life
and so I mean no I mean you know how
hard it is I mean it's a good thing I
mean you put now how many videos a day
how many days a week so I do minecraft
daily and then there's other other games
I play as well which I sort of on top of
that so seven days a week yeah it's
pretty about 11 or 12 videos I do a week
I do so I do a minecraft one every day
but you know we were speaking earlier
about the preparation that goes into
videos that's not all of them that
that's very specific to my lovely world
my main series there's other videos
where you know you could be sent a map
which is kind of like a story and you
kind of just play through it and you
know you could do three four five
episodes in a row you know kind of long
as long as you've still got energy and
got your voice like so you know so I
could you know do do one day recording
them and then that's that covered for
two weeks and so then I have the time to
you know spend you know a day or two
like working hard on one particular
video so that's that that's the way you
can kind of fit it in so you actually
have time to do it all and I want to
come back to that day to day and I think
this kind of intersects with it too
knowing that you know when you look at
the amount of viewers that you're
getting on this content and imagining
you know especially if you're still
doing so much of it yourself I mean your
overhead is low views are incredible
you're obviously doing well funny
financially so at what point did you
start thinking like okay you know one
point you're a bartender and a guy who's
studying at university in the next
moment you're like well hold on this
this is a real thing this isn't this
isn't just making a living like this is
this is building something that it's a
pretty big deal like I'm gonna have
opportunities based on how this is going
like do you remember when that started
happening yeah well I mean the very
specific day-to-day for producing videos
for my channel has hardly changed like
I've got you know I'm not doing it from
you know my bedroom now which is not you
know still in my house but the I'm not
doing it from a bedroom anymore but you
know the process of making videos like
hasn't changed coz there's enough
there's nothing you can really change
cuz because I don't want to bring help
in for that because I want it to stay so
true to me that hasn't changed it's just
other opportunities around there has
change you know for things that I could
do you know going forth like it's just
opened a little doors for me and so they
said that's that's the the big thing
that has changed but do you anticipate
you know because I mean at some point
you're going to be like well I want to
start a family or I want to try this or
I've got this project that if I want to
do this thing I'm going to have to let
some of that go is there this is it a
well I just hope I'll find somebody I
trust because I totally get it that
you're saying I enjoy that like I don't
want to let go of that I don't want it
to become just this enterprise or this
business that I'm just managing because
I the heart of it of you developing and
executing your creativity is something
you want to maintain but if you decide
you want to you know like money you'd
like your new project wonder quest
things like that if they start pulling
away that is it just a matter of finding
somebody you trust to do it for you or
is it pulling back I think is it would
have to be pulling back like the the
planning of the lovely world episodes
and the the commentary are the the two
things I could never give away there's
probably a few you know in like
literally you know so if I was gonna do
a video now of flying to the moon you
know there's probably someone I could
get to build the moon for me or you know
to build that map but the the commentary
and then the the preparation for the
actual video the coming up with ideas
that I'm gonna always retain as me so it
would have to be a case of you know you
know three or four maybe minecraft
videos a week rather than rather than
seven you know if that did happen you
know as you said like I wouldn't have an
option to start a family now like the
you know my schedule wouldn't permit for
that you know it would be unfair to the
the other people you know in my life to
you know it's no it's ten hours a day
you know if not more just you know and
then that's just getting just getting by
and then there's everything other
opportunities that go on top
you know which take up more time so you
know you're like how do you handle how
do you handle a week in LA like this um
so I always just stop pal like I do have
opportunities to record when I'm going
away but I'm so and I'm so particular
about kind of where I record and like
kind of my my setup like you know just
the yes mentalism having a stockpile
yeah like it if you here for a week the
previous week you had to do double yeah
two weeks yeah and then when I get it
I'm always I'm always quite far ahead in
terms of oh yeah record I always have
safety room it's just normally depending
on what series it's normally at least a
month safety room I have so you know
because if I'm so if I'm sick if I lose
my voice then you know I don't I don't
ever miss days you know like I've I
can't miss day is this I've never you
know like kind of out or just
traditional hate just to miss one day
because I'm that you've never missed a
day well like so since doing
I don't know from when it started but
since I started doing daily minecraft
videos I've not missed a day yet so okay
we kind of just you kind of just suck
just just to miss one because I have a
sore throat and I probably end up using
like Siri to do a commentary to text a
voice to do as I go people might be
disappointed but what about you gotta
have time for romance man I mean and I'm
not just talking like like some like me
let's just say there was a girl that you
could play some minecraft videos with
and then that could also be popular and
like help meet your quota I'm actually
talking about like in real life an
actual girl yeah so what's the question
do you have time for romance and yeah I
mean like mice my schedule isn't to the
point where I can't do it like I can go
out I can do things I can meet people I
mean like it's hard for me to duck to
[Music]
this it's hard for me to meet people
outside of the the YouTube space which
is lucky for me that you know I I have
met someone and it's just we've not kept
a secret like I'm with squashy who's a
duck in in Minecraft and you know and we
met through through minecraft as I meet
most people these days and she may or
may not be in the room
may not be to my left squirming in the
corner I was like you can stay in here
we typically said nobody can stay in
here but I just wanted to see her squirm
in the corner when I kind of made you
squirm but I asked Lily I was like you
think distemper you have a girlfriend
no she she was watching the video like
stamping and squashy playing and I was
like okay I hear a girl I hear a girls
voice that doesn't sound like ballistic
squid and unless he's changed a lot last
time I listened over your shoulder and I
know that's squashy I was like oh is
that is that stampy's girlfriend she was
like she was like well he doesn't say so
but it's pretty obvious right which is
kind of what you're saying I mean in
videos it's I never talk about personal
life it's just like I never even ref
talk about my life like I never
referenced real-life things like I never
mentioned like you know as foresee you
know I never mentioned what I had for
breakfast is always because you know
maybe a you know like I thought all
about eating something I thought what
I'm eating in Minecraft not real life so
but as you'll get your vlog Channel too
though that people get it yeah yeah so
there's another channel magic animal
Club which is kind of there's a few of
us it's a bit of a joint channel so
whenever we do want to do something that
is kind of outside of that outside of
the character you know that's kind of a
place where we can put like I'm the only
reason we do that is because people like
you know demander people are really
interested
they've got to know it's just like we
had to know right here and we had to
talk about it so the answer is yes there
is time for for girlfriend yeah and but
then you guys have made a decision okay
we're gonna do the vlog thing you're
gonna see is it Disneyland you can you
know we're just gonna you know what what
went into that decision like we mean we
was just we never feel the need to like
announce anything like we have anything
in our personal life we never feel you
know we're not we're not vlog it's like
well we've done a few vlogs but they're
always like we're doing a big thing like
you want to see this cool thing we're
doing like I've never done a vlog from
home just saying okay you know I've
never done just a general you know like
you know I think I'd be really boring at
that but you know if I'm doing
a really cool thing and I think you know
people would love to see us doing this
this is cool you know that's when we
vlogging you know if I happen to be with
squashy or whoever you know they're
gonna be in the vlog you know we're
gonna do it you know together but I
never feel like you know I need to
announce anything in my personal life I
kind of and it's kind of nice to have
that you know that boundary like like
you guys have you know a bit of that
that separation right one of the talking
about today I was true I was trying to
picture like surely you know the fact
that you guys are making videos together
is it makes it a little bit less of a
loner thing I mean like yeah you could
easily just sort of dive into this world
and just be doing everything by yourself
which is kind of what you you were doing
at one point so how is that how has it
been managing a relationship like that
and the logistical question are you guys
in the same room when you're talking to
each other in the game we're in the same
house but in a in a different room just
just for this easier just for sound
isolation yeah yeah yeah so that makes
it easy like that and we were recording
such as how your relationship works
there's a line down the middle of the
house is my side that's what we do yes
yes I mean I mean we were recording
before we met together like it was you
know it was that way around and you know
I've done videos with with other people
before that you mentioned earlier
ballistics weird you know like you who I
met when I either thousand subscribers
where when I met him and we have been
you know kind of unofficial partners for
a while you're not to the level that you
two are in the fact that we we're never
planning stuff together like he has
series on his channel which I'm kind of
a guest in and I'll jump in and be comic
relief and then vice versa I'll have a
series which you know like I'm very
controlling like I'll kind of plan you
know our plan what the series is and I
invite him in because he really makes me
laugh and so he's great but you can't
talk it's really only being ballistic
squid and now squashy that I've done
videos talking to people which is always
awkward for me because are you a control
freak I like to like if it's a point
where it's gray she is nodding her head
like if I'm doing a video on my channel
you know then like I feel like I am in
control and I want it the way I want it
but if I was a guest in know squids or
squeeze videos like I wouldn't try and
take control like I let them take
control in our you know let them Rena I
abide by their rules and go in the
direction they want so but like in real
life like okay it's we gotta get from
point A to point B and we're gonna go my
way and I don't think so can we have an
order of shake am i controlling we're
got a sigh I don't think like full work
stuff and video stuff like that that's
my obsession and that's when I'm gonna
really care you know if it's about like
what we're gonna have for dinner like I
Germany I'm not interested I don't I
don't care you know we can have what you
want worried you not like a personality
type or you laid-back or like more
tightly wound you know is there does it
carry over from the meticulous planning
that goes into your videos I think I
mean there's things that like you know
that would stress me out but I think I'm
generally laid-back about about most
things has the so did the relationships
start before yeah so so we though the
way we met was she squashy sent me a map
in mind and I will say we don't want you
to have minecraft me all have cinema map
we would just bring her over but we
don't have a fourth mic and it's just
it's also more entertaining for me
personally to watch her just react I'm
speaking trying to keep the woman silent
it's just sort of logistically working
out that way right now well we met in a
traditional way she sent me a Minecraft
map nice she said to her she said she
sent me a video like cuz you know people
send me maps all the time to you know
hoping that I'm gonna play through them
and do a video of them so she sent me a
stamp effets map that she made but she
made a video of her playing through it
and kind of talking about it and you
know and I thought the the map the map
was okay like the mat was pretty cool
but like I thought her commentary was
really funny like I thought she was
really good and she had I don't know how
many subscribers she had at the time but
I remember I was her 11th she's he'd
only been doing YouTube should be known
for her for a few months and so I went
and watched some of her videos I was
like she's really funny like this is
someone who you know really child
friendly bright happy this is someone
who I'd like to do videos with
looked out your window and she was
standing there I reached out to her you
know and you know I wanted to meet her
for a bit in chat you know before saying
about you know doing that I'll never go
let's do a video together so I talked
about you know the possibility of doing
a series together one kind of worked out
what that being and then we started
recording and so you know when you're
recording a song you're speaking to them
a lot and so yeah we met we went through
minecraft so she was kind of an a
collaborator first or yeah yeah
definitely we did videos together before
before we you know before this before we
met in person right and and then when
you the first time you incorporated I
know you'd incorporate a ballistic squid
already into videos but when you
incorporated her into videos what was
the fan reaction in how do your fans
react to changes and stuff in its
general there's that there's a lot of
negativity like any change like I needs
like I did a one-off series with with
Martin it would from the yogscast and
you know and i think was a great series
but like up until then all of that type
of video had been with squid and so you
know people generally react negatively
to change and so I think when I started
with squashy there was a bit of that I
mean it's always the minority you know
it's always a very loud minority right
you know but that was when we started
we're now you know we've been doing
videos for for quite a while now and you
know people love her and she's you know
she's got a strong channel as well and
you know her her own set of fans and you
know [ __ ] she's just kind of accepted
as you know as part of the you know the
the group of friends now did you start
dating before you met in person uh no
like we kind of you know we were kind of
talking and getting along and then you
know and then we we met we won't keep
grilling you about that we should talk
about the new stuff that you're working
on because there's like huge stuff a
wonder Kratts Quest
Wonder course wonder core you yes
there's a Wonder Quest is so this is off
my channel this is a new channel called
Wonder quest which is it's a joint
channel I'm doing with maker studios
we're kind of going into this together
and I had the idea from as soon as I
realized kids were watching I knew that
I wanted to do educational videos and so
and this was you know this is what that
that is and so it's a new channel where
it's it's a it's a brand new format to
where unlike my videos which are
completely unscripted these are
completely scripted you know there we
have producers of the show we it you
know it's shot like a show you know we
have multiple cameras you know and we
have overlays and music and sound
effects and it's but it's set within a
Minecraft yeah universe it's minecraft
yeah it's all my characters yeah it's
all the rapper worlds yeah that there is
also a side show called I wonder and
that is an animated show right and so
that that's sure to content the each
episodes about three or four minute four
minutes and that goes even more in depth
to the educational side whereas the main
show I mean it it's got to be
entertainment first because I was no
one's gonna watch it you know but you
know what's the story like in general so
it's it's kind of kinda like a Saturday
morning cartoon as a there's an evil
villain villain called heinous who's a
Playfish a car and you know and then
he's got his his two henchmen and
there's the wonder cube which has been
shattered and it's basically stopped
everyone from wandering like no one's
thinking like everyone's just kind of
turned dumb and and so we're trying to
piece it back together so each episode
we're like we're following Clues to try
and find a piece of the wonderment and
then there's certain obstacles we have
to try and get passed on are on our way
to doing that you know and we're
inevitably having to learn something to
get past those obstacles in what was the
motivation for kind of branching out I
just knew it was something that I that I
wanted to do I just knew as something
that would work so well in Minecraft and
you know minecraft has been used for
education for a while now like it's used
in schools quite a lot there's a a need
EU version of Minecraft which is an
educational version of Minecraft which
is officially released so it's not you
know it's not breaking like any doors
down in that way but that type of
entertaining video content is something
that you don't see see much of and it
just seemed like such an obvious thing
because it's not just a show that they
can watch because we're also releasing
the world you know the sets or the games
that we're playing in so with each
episode will release a world so people
can kind of do what we did and you know
kind of carry on playing and learn
you know beyond just watching the video
but how is it shut its shot like a show
it's not it's not like a live-action
show right because you've got a real
world a virtual world of Minecraft but
then you have to shoot like I'm talking
camera angles and characters and
blocking no pun intended
it's not it's not like an animation what
you just draw whatever you want you have
to a you have to build it then you have
to insert the characters and then see
you have to shoot it how does that work
how do you work camera angles in
Minecraft so yes so the first thing
building the set is a big thing when I
get there there's Minecraft yeah yes
that's easy but then even looked how
that stuff though so the filming so
we're we're in the game and then we have
characters that are invisible so they're
the they're the cameras and there are
settings you can do to have a smoother
camera and make it so you don't see any
of the menus you just see you know what
you know what you're seeing so it's the
first person perspective of invisible
characters edited together Tom's the
cameraman yeah but you know the amazing
you know yeah I think if you have to do
a crane shot in real life you know
you've got to get a crane you know of us
you got to press a button you can fly
the invisible carrier yeah so there's
lots of opportunities to do cool things
there and there are people doing this
or is this the first of its kind there
there's beaming there's been things that
I've done on my channel which are kind
of that in them yeah yeah you know and
people you know before me doing that
kind of thing I mean this is I mean this
is long-form content though you know
these are you know I mean it's all into
their basis it's not straight but if
they're all about 20 minutes or so so
this is long-form content and the you
know the printer view and the overlays
or the music and then the you know the
simpler to say if I'm throwing so an
item on the ground they don't just rely
on the minecraft sound you know they're
I don't you know let me ask you this
when you're your plane
stampy in this in this world are are you
controlling the character and voicing it
simultaneously yes so we're saying
you're doing there's a director are you
all in the same room are you in London
and shake Carl's in like the middle of
Idaho yeah so
it's if there's a couple of us there's
myself and then Adam Clark who plays
wizard keen who's kind of he's kind of
like my mentor he's the kind of guy
teaching me I'm kind of their pupil
we're in the UK and then there's the the
team at maker
and they're in LA so I got a bad sleep
pattern for recording late at night and
so what essentially I'm doing is the
commentary is still done live with the
action we don't just do a voiceover
session like after we've shot it so I'm
basically nodding I'm nodding the
character's head up and down
yeah and speaking and there are some
elements where you know there is a lot
of improvising that that goes into it
and there are some parts where it is
more of a you know there's oh there's a
horde of zombies coming we need to get
them and so you're setting up the scene
is there like a director who's like
you're hearing and he's like on skype or
something okay guys action is this yeah
is it is this amazing how similar to a
normal shoot a little like the logistics
are you know we have to face a live
action shoot it I mean I didn't think I
was like doing a play more than it's
like filming yeah you know what I mean
no it's still scene based I assume yeah
then you stop down it's like well let's
get that again I didn't like your
performance let's write but you there's
if you're building something or you know
you the same thing applies where you're
you have to redo it right yeah but I
like it yeah I mean if we're building so
we have to redo but there's very little
minecraft yeah you know it's it's more
of a story with it yeah yeah it is
you know puppets I think it's quite a
you know a nice thing to use you are we
kind of playing through there are some
times we might need to play something we
never have any hammer men are there it's
usually too you know but we will redo
the the scene a few times you know I'll
get specific things there sometimes you
know there's this - cam ops who are
invisible men and then you'll redo the
scene in like giving them different
assignments and there's a director who's
deciding all that stuff that yeah yeah
and sometimes if it's a bigger scene you
know sometimes we'll have a scene where
we need like a crowd and we need you
know like it's you know like a bigger
scene than we have more people helping
you know sometimes squashy might hop on
and be an extra character in the
background because it's needed and how
long I mean what how many episodes of
how late how
so there's 12 episodes we're doing free
seasons the first season is out now and
there's 12 episodes of that and they're
all they're all about 20 minutes so I'm
go down to about 15 I think some a
little bit low and how are you releasing
that because I know that when we're
recording this you're about to launch
yeah and then once it's launched you're
releasing them all all 12 episodes no
we're gonna be doing them weekly the
guns gonna be so this is the the I
wonder which is the animated show and
then one of the the main show Wonder
Quest is gonna be released each week and
so they're gonna be spaced out in that
way and how do you doing I guess they're
supplies of your videos too but for some
reason it just seems like more of an
issue when you're creating like an
original programming when you're
basically creating a show that is
intellectual property but you're using
minecraft is are there any like
copyright considerations for that kind
of thing yeah I mean the basically it
means we we have ween there's no
opportunity to bring it to TV for
example is is a big thing I mean the
Minecraft great in terms of their their
Terms of Use the fact they may spell out
very clearly like it says in the Terms
of Use you may you know put this content
on YouTube and and monetize it and you
know which is obviously they don't take
a cut no no but they you know they have
the best free advertising in the word
you know unless it is it's way better
than than any trailer so is this kind of
it you know a mutual benefit situation
right so you know and for things I say
if we wanted to bring out you know
merchandise or something you know we you
can't use any anything minecraft so it
does kind of limit kind of the the
potential of what these things can be
but for this kind of show like its home
is YouTube like there this is the place
where you know children are gonna want
to watch this this program so what now I
mean it sounds like Wonder Quest is you
know there's two more seasons that
you're committed to are you happy with
with it so far and what else are you
setting your sights on yeah I mean I'm
I'm super happy with how how Wonder
quest is like turned up and I'm you know
as I said as as we're recording this
it's not public yet so I'm anticipating
the the reaction and you know this is
something
then you know that the last year on so
just waiting to see what what people
think so hopefully as the time as I can
listen to this some nice comments and I
mean the next I mean the big thing for
me is obviously been so ties directly to
Minecraft the warriors that you know
once minecraft Rupp Minecraft popularity
starts to go down as you know inevitably
will is to try and make it so you know
the stampy cat character can kind of
live on in in some other form and
there's you know that there's nothing at
the moment but you know I'm heavily
thinking about you know other even other
mediums or other ways that stampy cat
can you know live as a character outside
of Minecraft so that's the the next big
project well you know we're we're in awe
of everything that you're doing and we
think it's awesome and obviously our
kids do so yes sign the table man and
that will be that will be some of our
kids can keep coming back to ya really
did happen did yes and Beth yo you
should you should come over to the Mike
and say something come on I'm not gonna
make you but I just said you should you
don't put on the headphones and
everything just full treatment you could
they can know that you were actually
here I was actually here that's her and
that's question back what's your
assessment I mean is there something
that you need to correct that he said um
not really
I mean yes he is quite controlling and
what else don't hold back
you know what you just earned your own
signature on this table yeah yes to find
a spot thanks for coming in guys
[Music]
and there you have it our conversation
with stampy cat and squashy she's got
she get we got her on that mic there at
the end so that's we did it got her
perspective I mean she was here the
whole time which I think we explained
but so it was only appropriate to bring
her on and give her a microphone tweet
at Joseph his Twitter handle is
stampylongnose stampylongnose not stampy
cat hashtag your biscuits let him know
what you thought of the conversation
also give us a review on iTunes we
appreciate that one of the cool things
that happened is right after we finished
recording this podcast we walked we took
him out of the the ear biscuits to do
here and walked out into the the main
part of the studio and to record the
good mythical morning appearance that he
made which has been up for a while at
the Minecraft game well yeah I won by
the way
and I and I thought that she would win
because you've been why now yeah you
know you really should feel a little
shame about that but questions were hard
for us you're our kids were here because
not just because we wanted to use them
in the game but because they really
really really really really wanted to
meet stampy this is probably dad meant
maybe the number one celebrity that they
would want to meet period oh yeah you
know and so and of course once some of
their friends found out that they were
meeting stampy they had to be here too
so we had all of our kids and some of
their friends here but we knew they were
here we said yeah we didn't know what I
wouldn't know where they were so as soon
as we get out into this or the main open
area of the studio they're all like
standing there and they begin clapping
like for Stanley as he comes out and it
was just it was an amazing moment of
course he's like the most gracious guy
you can tell you can totally tell he's
not one of these guys that is annoyed by
the fact that he's popular with children
he immediately started talking to each
one of them and you know Lily had made
some stuff for him and anyway he it was
it was pretty awesome but they
definitely got more out of that moment
than they've ever gotten out of anything
that we provided as an actual father
hey if that's what it takes to be a cool
dad or a good dad I don't know you know
it's like I'll pull out that stop you
know you'll pull out that stop I'll pull
out you know how they say pull out all
the stops yeah you'll pull out that
stuff that doesn't Garrett coming to
your studio is one of the stops so but I
think you pull out the stops to make
things go faster right see you I have no
clue what a stop is I think you play a
card you know what playing the stampy
card as a father to become a cool dad
the funny thing is when you talk about
pulling out the stops you know that
picture and I have no clue why maybe you
can explain this an organ are there
stops in an Oregon I think that good
that could very well be what it I'm sure
it has some sort of word phrase origin
thing and it could be I don't know I
mean it's not pulling out a doorstop
right because there's multiple stops and
you pull them out and then something
happens you're gonna look it up right
now just to find out you know I mean the
music playing that we're sitting they
know you can stick around if they want
you to learn something Wow assuming
you're going to be able to figure it out
by looking on the internet which is a
questionable source often pulling out
all the stops origin that's what I would
Google if I was googling it find
anything an allusion to organ stops
there you go how did you even know that
I don't know I don't know an allusion to
organ stops which control the loudness
and tones of a pipe organ when all are
pulled out the working super loud well
well it can play all tones
simultaneously I'm pulling out all the
stops to reserve or hold back nothing
they pulled out all the stops for that
gala wedding that's that's the Wikipedia
link you had you had some mystical
insight I had knowledge emptied the tank
give one's all go all out either you're
clairvoyant or you've heard you've heard
that before
wait what's your choice let's say that a
party okay I've got a lot of organist
friends all right you don't know about
next week with that with another
interesting tidbit about word origins
not probably not that's probably the
only time that's ever gonna happen Stu
shirt will pull out all the stops for
yes right stop yeah just one stop
[Music]
[Music]